[Musique]
regardez ce que j'ai là aujourd'hui je
suis sur mon nouveau Skate électrique
alors je voulais vous parler skate je
voulais vous montrer ça c'est le Eden de
evolve c'est le bambou bambou 2 en 1
alors il existe différentes versions on
va regarder aujourd'hui ce skate alors
je vous lis tout de suite je suis pas
skateur je me suis mis à pas longtemps
j'ai essayé il y a quelques temps j'ai
trouvé ça extrêmement cool donc waouh
trop de soleil hyper mal donc je vais
vous expliquer pourquoi j'ai choisi ce
skate pourquoi il est intéressant en
quoi il est facile même pour les mecs
comme moi qui sont vraiment des nazes et
qui débutent complètement je vais vous
expliquer pourquoi ce bambou je trouve
déjà super super canon il existe une
finition carbone mais j'ai choisi
celui-là bref on va tout regarder
aujourd'hui sur le ADN addine j'arrive
pas à prononcer je sais pas exactement
comment ça se prononce de evolve et vous
allez voir que ce skate là il envoie du
bois mais très très fort
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors la question c'est pourquoi
pourquoi est-ce que je me mets au skate
aujourd'hui à bientôt 43 ans est-ce que
c'est le moment de monter sur une
planche et risquer de se casser la
gueule oui bah ouais à tout âge dès
qu'on peut quoi que l'autre jour j'ai
mis mon beau-père dessus première chute
bim bam je suis cassée faut faire
extrêmement attention personnellement
c'est un truc que j'avais vraiment envie
de faire depuis très longtemps je sais
pas si vous le savez mais je vous l'ai
déjà dit je suis un grand fan de cuisine
et ça fait des années que je devais voir
rider alors attention je ne suis pas lui
je suis pas rider j'ai pas son niveau ni
son expérience mais pour autant ça donne
vraiment envie et l'autre fois on a un
faisait un événement avec la marque oppo
et puis il y a un collègue qui est venu
qui avait un petit sketch bah est-ce que
je peux essayer j'ai fait du skate dans
les couloirs je fais du skate un peu
partout je me suis bien m'arrête et je
me suis dit j'ai vraiment envie ça me
donne vraiment envie donc du coup j'ai
regardé je me suis regardé et j'ai vu
que la marque evolve elle était juste
incroyable attention on se parle ici
d'une marque très haut de gamme ce skate
là dans la config que j'ai on a 2648
euros sur la version avec le kit de
conversion parce qu'en fait il y a deux
versions de ce skate là alors il y en a
plusieurs en fait vous choisissez plein
de planche soit en bambou soit en
carbone personnellement bonbons je
trouve extrêmement canon très joli ça
m'a vraiment séduit et en plus de ça il
existe une déclinaison soit vous l'avez
en roue de skate petite roue normal pour
venir rider en ville c'est la version
Street soit vous avez la version tout
chemin avec des roues un peu plus grosse
moi je les monte en tout chemin alors le
tout chemin il ira un peu moins vite que
la version Street on aura une autonomie
qui sera un peu plus faible parce que
forcément le moteur faut qu'il entraîne
des roues un peu plus grosses donc
forcément on ira un peu moins loin mais
pour autant je préfère parce qu'on a des
vrais sensations un peu plus amortisse
ça me plaît énormément mais j'ai quand
même pris le kit ou je peux venir le
changer avec le kit de conversion qui
coûte un peu plus cher un peu plus et ça
aurait été contre s'en priver vu les
gens le prix du skate comme ça si demain
je vais passer en street je peux si je
veux revenir en tout chemin je peux le
faire donc ça je trouve que c'est
vraiment génial
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il existe un kit de conversion pour le
transformer de modèle street en mode
chemin du mode chemin en mode street
tout inclus ici c'est que j'aime bien
aussi chez evolve c'est qu'ils ont
vraiment pensé à tout tout est situé ici
alors je l'ai pas encore changé moi je
suis vraiment resté qu'en mode tout
chemin parce que c'est vraiment un mode
que j'adore mais voyez tout est situé là
vous avez là vous avez vos roulettes qui
sont juste hyper mouse alors bon c'est
évident je l'ai pas changé mais
peut-être que je le ferai un de ces
quatre faut dire que le mode tout chemin
est tellement génial et tellement
pratique que globalement on n'a pas
envie de s'emmerder ce qui est cool
c'est que pour un mec comme moi qui suis
pas habitué à rider sur une planche de
dire j'ai fait du snow il y a longtemps
j'ai fait le sketch j'étais tout gamin
mais je me marrais mais j'étais vraiment
déjà extrêmement naze je fais un peu de
surf mais je suis vraiment naze là
dedans donc bon c'est pas mon univers
mais j'ai vraiment une envie ça me plaît
les sensations elles sont géniales et
bien avec ce skate là on a des vraies
sensations de glisses comme on est sur
un longboard on a un vrai bon maintien
je trouve ça super rassurant et
personnellement je prends un pied
monstrueux à venir en faire il y a un
truc qui est super important pensez
vraiment à venir vous protéger protéger
votre tête mettez un casque pour éviter
les déconvenues d'ailleurs aujourd'hui
c'est une vidéo qui est et en
partenariat avec Sénat je vous montre la
boîte du casque quand il arrive chez
vous vous l'avez là il est emballé de
cette manière là alors c'est très simple
très clair très bien fichu alors il
existe le casque dans différentes
teintes vous allez la voir soit en noir
mat soit en blanc mat soit en gris mat
c'est très matte chez Sénat à
l'intérieur là vous avez une petite doc
qui vous explique comment ça marche ça
c'est plutôt bien fichu ok un cap pour
venir le recharger en USBA et en USB C
et puis vous avez une petite protection
petite housse pour venir l'emmener avec
vous très facilement si vous voulez pas
l'abîmer voilà ça c'est assez malin et
le casque en lui-même regardez comment
il est fait alors c'est un casque qu'on
peut venir utiliser sur un vélo qu'on
peut utiliser sur une trottinette qu'on
peut utiliser sur ce qu'on veut c'est
une coque qui est faite en polycarbonate
moulée qui va être doublé de rembourrage
à l'intérieur qui sont complètement
amovibles et lavables donc en termes
d'hygiène on a ce qu'il faut une
jugulaire qui est en bilan faut bien
évidemment régler la taille ça paraît
logique vous avez un Spinlock vous venez
régler le tour de tête ici que vous
venez serez comme ça ça date vraiment à
toutes les têtes et vous soyez vraiment
en sécurité il existe en small en médium
et en L moi ici je l'ai en médium c'est
pas une très grosse c'est un casque qui
est totalement ventilé également pour
que ce soit respirant pour votre tête
avec des haut-parleurs qui vont situer
de chaque côté au niveau de vos oreilles
mais qui n'obstruent pas vos oreilles
donc il y a une vraie sécurité ici c'est
très très rassurant et vous avez un
micro qui va venir capter le son de
votre voix c'est un casque intelligent
c'est un casque connecté qui vous
permettra de faire énormément de choses
alors vous avez plusieurs boutons vous
avez toute une partie ici sur la partie
gauche avec plus avec moins pour le son
et un petit bouton central et vous avez
également un petit bouton à l'arrière
c'est le bouton scénario et vous venez
le recharger là vous avez également des
LED à l'arrière pour venir vous voir
lorsque vous êtes en train de rider pour
venir l'allumer c'est facile vous laisse
appuyer le plus et boutons central une
fois pendant une seconde hello il vous
parle on peut le mettre en français
également et ensuite vous montez vous
baissez le volume vous voyez il me l'a
dit il faut une connectique j'ai mon
téléphone qui est connecté là j'ai mon
bouton Sénat alors le bouton scénario
par mail regardez qui permet de venir
activer et d'avoir différents modes
d'affichage je peux le faire clignoter
je le laisse en fixe qu'il y a de
différentes manières voilà lights off on
éteint les LED ici et lorsque je veux
mettre de la musique par exemple sur mon
iphone je suis connecté et le son via
directement de mon casque là regardez
voilà il y a du son et je l'ai sur ma
tête est-ce qu'il vraiment bien c'est
que lorsque je prends mon casque je le
mets comme ça je la juste j'entends la
musique et pour autant j'entends tout ce
qui se passe à côté donc s'il y a des
voitures des vélos d'autres personnes je
sais exactement ce qui se passe ça c'est
vachement bien en plus ici ça me fait un
play pause vous voyez là hop là on
entend là pause j'en mets play et là je
monte le son et là je baisse le son
alors le son est un peu médium on s'en
doutera mais ça permet quand même
d'avoir sa musique avec toi très
facilement en plus de ça vous pouvez
répondre à des appels téléphoniques vous
pouvez venir converser jusqu'à 4
personnes grâce à la fonction intercom 4
personnes c'est du Bluetooth 4.1 ans et
vous connecter jusqu'à 900 m et c'est un
casque qui est pas très lourd qui fait
394 g donc pour aller se balader ça va
on est bien donc on peut converser avec
des amis on intercom lorsque vous faites
des sorties en vélo en trottinette en
rail dans ce que vous voulez c'est vous
qui voyez vous pouvez écouter de la
musique on peut répondre à un appel
téléphonique très facilement et en plus
de ça vous pouvez avoir votre GPS
directement si vous avez une application
sur votre smartphone ou sur votre montre
connectée et bien vous allez guider par
la voix tourne à gauche tourne à droite
prends telle rue principale prend ça
c'est super pratique vous avez en plus
l'advince noise control qui va venir
réguler le son environnant pour ne pas
déranger lorsque vous êtes en train de
converser avec des amis et vous avez
également une application vous allez
pouvoir utiliser pour votre couplage
intelligent pour vos paramètres de base
alors vous allez pas l'extrêmement loin
avec l'application mais elle vous
servira également pour venir maintenir
votre casque à jour choisissez la langue
donc là il est en anglais je vais le
mettre en français vous voyez j'ai les
instructions vocales et fait local si
besoin et comme ça mon casque va bien me
parler en français et c'est beaucoup
mieux après vous avez quelque paramètres
coupage intelligent intercom paramètres
de base guide rapide manuel
d'utilisation voilà vas-y c'est donc un
casque je vais vous recommander pour
toutes vos sorties il existe dans
différentes couleurs différentes
finitions moi j'en ai deux ici qui est
vraiment extrêmement sympa dites moi
lequel peut vous intéresser bien
évidemment je vous mets un lien juste en
bas dans la description et merci à Sénat
d'avoir sponsorisé cette vidéo
[Musique]
alors je vous explique ça c'est ma
planche et cette planche elle est super
cool pourquoi parce que déjà elle a un
amorti dingue donc lorsque vous montez
dessus ça amorti c'est super cool c'est
hyper canon en plus ce que j'aime là
dessus c'est que comme on a affaire du
bon bout on a un truc très surfeur je
trouve très surfeur californien qui est
hyper Cali il est très grande roue que
vous avez là elles sont géniales alors
elles permettent une tenue de pavé qui
est ouf vous avez toute la batterie là
qui est positionné tout en dessous ici
vous venez l'allumer les tendres ici de
l'autre côté vous avez le petit truc
pour venir le recharger donc vous venez
l'insérer alors vous avez un truc qui
fait un bruit de dingue regardez
lorsqu'il est temps de venir le
recharger je le branche juste là là et
ça c'est une soufflerie ça fait un bruit
côté ce truc mais ça vous le recharge
alors je sais plus en combien de temps
vous voyez ici mais bon voilà pratique
voilà ça va plutôt bien ici à l'arrière
les moteurs les courroies courroies qui
vont être adaptés à votre roue donc si
vous mettez les petites roues de skate
et pas les grosses les petits trous plus
pour la ville et bien ça sera des
courroies qui seront un peu différentes
mais ça vous l'avez dans votre kit pour
venir le changer et après ben voilà il y
a plus qu'un alors c'est de la chambre à
air donc ça c'est cool avec vous mettre
du 3,5 bars vous voyez juste ici petite
chambre à vous pouvez changer donc si
vous crevez aussi un problème et bon on
peut venir le changer donc ce qui est
très cool avec ce skate c'est
qu'effectivement et bien on vient
changer on vient réparer on vient
bricoler on peut venir le moduler donc
ça c'est quand même super bien et puis
surtout vous avez un vrai grip ici ça ça
permet de tenir qui est super cool parce
que lorsque vous accélérez ça très très
fort lorsque vous accélérez lorsque vous
tournez vous avez une tenue dessus qui
est vraiment incomparable alors j'ai
pris deux trois notes histoire de tout
vous dire vu que j'ai pas appris les
données par cœur ce qui est dingue c'est
la vitesse en fait vous allez en version
Street donc avec les petits trous
jusqu'à 45 km/h c'est juste démentiel
version tout chemin comme j'ai là avec
les grosses roues c'est du 40 km/h enfin
il faut choisir son mode moi je reste à
25 parce que je fais quand même hyper
gaffe je vous le dis la loi c'est 25 km
heure pas plus vous avez deux moteurs de
3000 watts c'est un truc qui est juste
démentiel une autonomie en street avec
les petites roues de 65 km vous pouvez
quand même vous balader et là ici on
touche chemin de 40 km autant vous dire
que vous êtes quoi faire et après ce qui
est cool c'est que sur votre
télécommande vous avez plein
d'indicateurs qui vous permettent de
savoir sur quel mode vous êtes vous
pouvez monter les pente jusqu'à 30
degrés ce qui est aussi juste dingue et
regardez je vous montre parce que alors
moi je fais le mode écho et le mode
Sport les autres modes le corsicost je
suis pas encore bien bien cueuse custom
parce qu'on peut venir customiser ici
grâce à une app regardez je vous montre
déjà ça regardez sur votre télécommande
donc moi là vous avez plusieurs
indicateurs vous avez la distance
parcourue donc aujourd'hui j'ai fait 4
km les 43 % c'est pourcentage du skate
l'indicateur que vous avez juste en
dessous ici et bien c'est le niveau de
batterie de votre télécommande la voie
de vitesse vous voyez la puissance max
et là vous voyez effectivement on vous
en êtes et là vous voyez votre vitesse
en kilomètres heures ce qui fait que si
je le fais accéléré regardez vous voyez
hop 1 km/h on arrête donc là j'appuie
ici ça me permet de déclencher
l'accélérateur parce que si j'accélère
sans déclencher là et ben il part pas
alors c'est une petite sécurité qui peut
venir vous sauver la vie parce que si
vous appuyez comme ça bah il part pas et
ça c'est le frein alors là il y a pas de
sécu vous appuyez vous freiner attention
venez vraiment vous pencher derrière ce
que ça ferait vraiment fort et là vous
choisissez vous naviguez entre les modes
et là vous l'allumez vous l'éteignez là
vous voyez vous êtes connecté en
Bluetooth
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et vous avez également une petite housse
qui vous servira à venir ranger votre
télécommande et tout le bazar que vous
avez à l'intérieur je trouve ça
extrêmement pratique et déjà vous avez
un petit mot qui est très sympa un petit
mot d'accueil qui vient de la marque là
qui vous explique si c'est ça qui vous
demande de mettre un petit pouce sur
Google bon ok alors là vous avez de quoi
mettre votre télécommande et la
recharger à l'intérieur tout est bien
fait bien pensé après c'est premium ça
coûte quand même relativement cher vous
avez une clé bref vous avez tout votre
nécessaire pour si vous voulez partir
rider loin vous avez votre mallette avec
vous pouvez l'emmener je trouve ça une
fois de plus assez malin et plutôt bien
fichu donc par défaut c'est le mode ECO
comme ça enfin vous commencez vous
n'êtes même pas en mode ECO vous êtes
sur un mode stand by vous passez en écho
et après vous montez le mode Sport
s'envoi davantage le mode Corsa sa
tartine à Max et puis après que c'est
les custom customisation qu'on peut
faire grâce à l'appli et le mode Corsa
je vais vous montrer juste
l'accélération alors sans monter dessus
parce que je suis pas un fou furieux
mais regardez juste là quand il accélère
à vide vous allez voir le truc qui est
quand même vraiment donc là je suis en
écho j'appuie ça part c'est vraiment
vraiment cool ça part hyper hyper
doucement donc ça c'est l'écho alors le
mode sport je me penche bien vous voyez
ça part beaucoup plus fort donc ça c'est
le sport je vais essayer le mode Corsa
que je fais pas j'ai jamais essayé parce
que c'est un truc sauvage il y a des
progressivement ce que je vais éviter de
me tuer je le pense vraiment d'avant
[Musique]
donc le mode Corsa ça appuie énormément
tout pardon en fait ça envoie les Vals à
fond et c'est bien personnellement j'ai
pas encore niveau donc je me mets en
sport j'y vais à la cool et j'évite de
me faire mal surtout alors soyons clairs
moi je suis pas très fort je suis pas un
skateur j'ai jamais appris le skate
quand j'étais gamin j'aimais bien mais
j'avais une petite planche mais histoire
de bricoler pas plus que ça donc je suis
vraiment pas un skateur et je suis pas
particulièrement ce qui était par contre
ce que je trouve génial avec celui-là
comme ça longboard je trouve qu'on
apprend très facilement on prend ses
repères très facilement alors après on
comprend très facilement que il faut
envoyer un peu de purée pour tenir en
place et la force centrifuge fatalement
mais on peut y aller à différents
niveaux on n'est pas obligé de se faire
mal voyez on peut tourner maîtriser
comme ça et je trouve ça vraiment génial
parce que une fois de plus si vous vous
êtes pas skateur vous voulez vous lancer
vous voulez acheter en super steak il
coûte quand même un peu cher vous pouvez
y aller regardez faire des tours de
rond-point comme ça en vous penchant et
pour autant ça ne bouge pas voyez et ça
amorti ça absorbe en mode tout chemin et
je trouve ça super cool et après quand
vous voulez vous appuyez ça part ça
monte 25 km/h et après vous reprenez les
virages comme ça et une fois de plus
vous dis ça je suis très loin d'être en
skateur donc si vous savez faire du
skate si vous avez l'habitude ça sera
vachement plus simple et ça freine c'est
un truc important à savoir c'est que ça
freine vraiment fort là je suis en
pleine descendre vous voyez on est sur
les freins ça va m'arrêter et on peut
venir se balader on peut venir rider en
toute sécurité et je trouve ça
personnellement vachement rassurant
quand une fois de plus comme moi vous
êtes pas skateur voilà c'est super
simple d'autant plus qu'ici il y a des
trous de partout et ben ça marche ça
absorbe donc je trouve ça vraiment
vraiment rassurant après le truc où il
faut faire vachement gaffe c'est les
portes qui vont s'ouvrir les
automobilistes qui vous calcule pas ils
vont un mec debout il calcule pas
forcément que vous êtes sur un skate il
calcule pas forcément que vous allez
aller vite et que ça peut
potentiellement être dangereux mais ça
c'est le truc il peut vraiment venir
jouer des tours donc faites vachement
gaffe lorsque vous venez vous déplacer
que ce soit en skate ou en trottinette
d'autant plus que les pistes cyclable
les piétons aussi mettre les voitures
calcule pas aujourd'hui ils font un peu
n'importe quoi dans les villes ils vous
mettent des pistes cyclables comme ici
par exemple vous voyez c'est une petite
rue et il y a une piste cyclable qui
passe juste là ce qui fait que vous
allez avoir un vélo ou un skate ou
n'importe qui qui arrive et la bagnole a
l'impression que vous arrivez en sens
interdit donc faut faire extrêmement
gaffe si on veut pas risquer de se faire
mal et là vous voyez par exemple là une
bagnole là qui est comme ça une autre
qui se gare l'autre avec les warning on
sait pas l'autre qui se marqueulé donc
voilà il faut frayer son chemin et comme
la seule protection que j'ai c'est mon
casque alors après je pourrais mettre
des gants je pourrais mettre des
genouillères et des coudières mais bon
voilà je me suis pas encore cassé la
gâche parce que quand je me casserai la
gueule ça me calmera un peu je ferai ça
et pour l'instant en tout cas voyez je
me marre bien donc ce que je trouve
aussi bien avec cette board c'est que
c'est un GTR je sais pas si vous
connaissez volve c'est des skate très
haut de gamme c'est un GTR amélioré qui
va avoir plus de performances qui va
avoir une meilleure autonomie qui va
envoyer un peu plus de purée bon après
on peut toujours acheter le GTR qui est
un peu moins cher je dirais que celle-là
là le Adine si vous avez la règle
donnez-moi le nom parce que j'arrive pas
à le prononcer je trouve ça juste ouf
c'est vachement bien et une fois de plus
accélère un peu et attendez je vais
mettre un mode Corsa il semble marrer un
peu et voir jusqu'où ça accélère ouais
je suis à 25 pas plus protégé plutôt
bien alors peut-être qu'il y a un truc à
venir débrider dans l'application j'en
sais rien mais comme il est là je me
remets en mode sport ça va éviter de me
faire mal en tout cas voilà pour venir
se marrer pour venir rider il y a
vraiment de quoi faire regardez hop là
c'est juste de ouf point de détail qui
coule sur le skate vous avez un
éclairage regardez là vous voyez un
petit éclairage à l'arrière qui va vous
dire lorsque vous accélérez lorsque vous
freinez alors c'est son salaire un peu
avertir très honnêtement c'est vraiment
planqué donc c'est vraiment histoire
d'avoir un truc un petit peu rigolo
c'est histoire de venir customiser son
skate après customiser aussi dans
l'application la couleur vraiment le
faire comme vous voulez mais une fois de
plus c'est tellement bas et personne ne
verra jamais je pense pas que ça sera
quelque chose si ce n'est d'avoir un
truc qui est un peu marrant et qu'on
peut venir personnaliser regardez voilà
je sais pas comment vous le verrez
imaginez une bagnole qui est derrière
vous vous mettez à accélérer et à
freiner globalement regardez on voit
rien quoi et dernier élément qui a son
importance c'est un skate qui fait 13 kg
12,5 kg et 6 séquelles en version petit
trou et 13,4 je crois en version rostru
alors bon vous me direz 13 kg c'est bien
parce que lorsque vous roulez avec c'est
stable ça bouge pas ça c'est sûr mais le
problème des 13 kg c'est lorsque vous
voulez le porter l'emmener avec vous
c'est une galère vous le prenez sous le
bras il est extrêmement lourd vraiment
très très lourd donc ça je recommande
pas c'est galère et moi je l'avais
acheté pour l'emmener à Paris et monter
au cinquième étage avec parce que je
suis au cinquième étage sans ascenseur
et autant vous dire que 13 kg la
globalement je le sens pas trop
[Musique]
tout en sachant que vous avez ici une
application leur application et vous
permet d'enregistrer vos ride vous
pouvez venir ici enregistrer vos règles
bon personnellement j'ai pas utilisé
pour enregistrer mes ride vous pouvez
avoir le nombre de ride des personnes
j'en sais rien c'est pas ton truc qui
m'intéresse là j'ai un connecté mon
board alors regardez je vais venir le
customiser avec différents custom custom
1 custom 2 custom 3 et regarder je peux
mettre ici l'accélération c'est quoi
power set old current output of the
board donc power à fond accélération je
veux choisir soit minimum soit max le
freinage aussi agressif ou pas et je
peux en mettre 3 comme ça je peux venir
customiser c'est très très très cool et
très très pratique ensuite j'ai un petit
profil si je suis en mai je peux
regarder s'il y a des mises à jour j'ai
parlé d'ailleurs tiens une petite mise à
jour à faire check for update ok il y a
une petite mise à jour à faire ici donc
vous voyez c'est quand même super
pratique alors ça c'est bien et je vous
le dis le tarif c'est noté il est de
2648 euros pour le board alors dans la
version comme j'ai les moins
c'est-à-dire avec les deux versions je
peux venir le moduler avec le côté ville
avec le côté plus tout terrain on va
l'avoir un peu moins cher si vous voulez
une des deux configurations mais le
différence de tarif est globalement pas
énorme d'ailleurs c'est un skate qui
vous intéresse j'ai un lien
d'affiliation je vous mets le lien
quelque part en bas dans la description
pour venir l'acheter si vous intéresse
moi personnellement je dois reconnaître
que je me marier avec
vous savez tout sur ce skate électrique
pourquoi est-ce que je l'ai pris
pourquoi est-ce qu'il est intéressant
pourquoi est-ce que c'est cool aussi de
faire du skate électrique alors moi j'en
faisais pas c'était du vélo c'était de
la trotte c'est toujours du vélo en
ville mais le skate c'est vachement bien
alors attention faites gaffe à vous ça
reste quand même quelque chose de
dangereux on peut rapidement tomber on
peut rapidement se faire mal les
automobilistes sont pas forcément prêts
à nous voir avec des skate donc voilà on
y va avec parcimonie néanmoins j'ai
découvert vraiment un plaisir de venir
rider avec ça en ville pour déplacer
c'est facile je vous dis l'inconvénient
c'est qu'il est quand même relativement
lourd 13 kg quand vous montez des
escaliers et il faut l'emmener avec soi
mais c'est juste génial donc je sais pas
ce que vous en pensez est-ce que ça peut
vous intéresser ce skate c'est vraiment
une découverte que je voulais faire
partager avec vous personnellement je
l'adore je continuerai peut-être à
essayer d'autres skate donc dites-moi ça
peut vous intéresser on en parle en bas
dans les commentaires et puis moi je
vous dis à bientôt puis je continue je
repars je vais arriver voilà bisous
c'est parti on est Avant Guingamp
[Musique]